the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so let's look at the example or the
in-class exercise with while loops oh
good we got got some varying responses
here perfect so the code is you're in
the lost forest go left or right okay so
here the while loop is checking if the
input is equal to this particular string
okay and if it is type the same thing
again and ask them for more input so my
question was what happens when you type
in capital r h HT and i think the
majority of the class is getting it
right and maybe the people who got
answered this are maybe changing their
answer to something else but you're
right so you ask the question again go
left or right and that's because python
again is very very particular right
we're telling it that the user input
must match this string exactly so
capital righ T is going to be is going
to even though it says right it's it
doesn't match up so if you wanted I'll
just show you in this example here if
you wanted to to take care of that case
then you'd add this little is the loop
this little you'll expand on this line
right here which says while n is equal
equal to right or n is equal equal to
capital R IG HT or whatever other cases
you'd want to take care of